[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
me voici devant vous en chair et en os
me voici également devant vous sur cette
petite photo derrière moi ici je suis à
votre droite
en fait qu'est ce qui fait qu'on devient
les gens que l'on devient dans notre
parcours
qu'est ce qui fait que des gens qui nous
inspire plus que d'autres à côté de moi
sur la photo c'est ma jumelle mirlin
magimel men jumelles appareil magimel
en fait elle est née avec des besoins
particuliers
et tout au long de sa vie elle allait
pas atteindre plus que le développement
de 24 mois environ donc rapidement je me
suis rendu compte dans ma vie que même
si je voulais être là pour elle je
devais être capable de répondre à ces
besoins de ne pas en fait mais posé et
comprendre également que des gens
avaient des limites qu'on avait beau
évoluer dans le même monde mais en fait
on partageait pas nécessairement le même
système
me reviennent a toujours été ma première
éducation ma première inspiration à
l'école de la vie baisse a été mon
meilleur professeur quand on est petit
et on joue tout le monde ensemble
est ce qu'on sait qui va avoir besoin
d'être au cours de son parcours parce
que tout le monde parcours particulier
est bien propre à soi même
est-ce qu'on c est ce qu on joue avec le
prochain premier ministre personne on ne
sait pas en fait tout ce qu'on s'en va
quand on est tout petit et qui en fait
tu vas voir justement besoin d' aide au
tour au cours de son parcours comme on
dit en haïti mais qu'on dit aussi en
afrique et à bien des places à travers
le monde
ça prend un village pour éduquer un
jeune donc j'ai la chance de travailler
en persévérance scolaire j'ai la chance
d'accompagner quotidiennement des
milliers de jeunes qui ont besoin de
cette aide là pour pouvoir parvenir à
leurs fins au cours de leur parcours
le village est créé oui à l'école et
créer avec le professeur mais crypte et
aussi avec les jeunes universitaires
spécifiquement dans des projets
particuliers viennent suivre les jeunes
du primaire et du secondaire à l'école
et en plus de les accompagner au
quotidien dans leurs compétences
disciplinaires donc pourquoi en
mathématiques j'apprends tu me mets mes
tables de multiplication ou encore
additionner ou quoi que ce soit mais je
vais le mettre
d'une façon tangible dans les projets
que je vais faire au delà d'être
accompagnés de jeunes universitaires qui
devient modèle pour ces jeunes là il ya
aussi de l'industrie qui vient faire
partie du village de cet enfant là
comment les gens qui travaillent déjà à
l'extérieur peuvent venir apprendre à
nos jeunes comment d'une façon quotidien
ils sont en train d'appliquer ce qu'ils
ont appris aux autres à leur époque
à l'école il faut également s'adapter en
fait aux différents milieux douce qu'on
se trouve par exemple lorsqu'on
travaille avec des jeunes dans les
communautés autochtones à ce petit
village leur s'ajoute un animateur local
pour pouvoir faire le lien avec la
communauté
donc tout ce village là on peut
développer à travers des projets qui
inspire les jeunes
donc au delà de suivre les cours à
l'école où on apprend juste du français
pour le français ou la géographie pour
la géographie
il faut aussi qu'on apprend à cohade à
développer nos compétences fondamentales
le système de l'éducation est basé sur
un triste fait qu'on faisait en fait
l'école pour avoir accès à des
professions qui était plus libérale
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation de
plein emploi
aujourd'hui il ya possibilité
d'entreprendre aujourd'hui une
possibilité de mettre ses compétences à
profit pour la société
de quelle façon on peut faire ça aussi
c'est d'apprendre à développer son
estime de soi d'apprendre à développer
la collaboration d'apprendre à
développer la communication à travers
des projets qui nous stimule aussi parce
que au-delà d'apprendre justement des
matières de base c'est de savoir que
dans à travers nos cours on va
développer des projets pour venir avec
un résultat final
la fin de l'année où on va pouvoir
produire un vrai produit
quoi de plus stimulant que se dire cette
semaine mon accompagnateur d'une telle
industrie va m'aider à pouvoir faire un
jeu vidéo à la fin de l'année développer
l'intelligence artificielle chez les
jeunes que c'est une nouvelle discipline
qui n'existait pas mais ils en auront
besoin dans quelques années pour être
nos clients nos bénéficiaires nos
employés quoi de mieux aussi que
développer l'art un haut niveau et ne
pas seulement faire ensemble une petite
pièce de théâtre dans le gymnase de son
école ou encore exposés certains de nos
notre vision de faire partie d'une
exposition dans un vrai musée les jeunes
c'est pas la société demain il évolue
avec nous donc il faut qu'ils fassent
partie aussi de notre village savoir
stimuler les gens pour voir de quelle
façon en fait on est capable d'aller
plus loin ensemble comment la société a
besoin de tous et chacun
je sais qu'au cours de notre parcours on
peut être inspiré par certaines
personnes il peut y avoir des certains
agissements qui arrivent dans notre vie
qui fait qu'on décide d'aller un peu
plus loin où que ça nous accroche et
bien ici il y a aussi des exemples
tangibles
il ya marie lou ici sur l'écran que
mariloup wolfe qu'elle est à
l'université elle a décidé qu'elle
voulait faire la différence
elle aussi elle a décidé que comme l
étudiant en cinéma elle allait devenir
un accompagnatrice pour les jeunes en
cinéma qui fait qu'elle est allée plus
loin qu'elle a développé le programme de
devenir gestionnaire d'un programme de
cinéma et aujourd'hui elle est avec nous
comme directrice des opérations
à côté d'elles on voit yazid yazid est
un jeune qui a eu la chance d'avoir de
la robotique dans sa classe lorsqu'il
était petit ça a piqué sa curiosité sa
développer ses passions aujourd'hui gaz
et des conseillers techniques en
robotique et accompagne lui même des
jeunes dans leur parcours académique et
leur permet de faire des robots à la fin
de l'année pour un jeune quoi de mieux
de développer tout au long de son
parcours académique dans son année en
fait
un produit qui va présenter avec fierté
devant ses parents devant ces scènes
devant sa famille devant la communauté
quoi de mieux de travailler sur un
projet avec les amis de la classe avec
les collègues et d'arriver en fait à une
performance qu'on n'aurait pas pensé
qu'on pouvait aller jusqu'à là quoi nous
aussi quand on vient parfois de milieux
défavorisés qu'on n'a pas accès
nécessairement comme tout le monde mais
comme la majorité ou comme la société le
voudrait a de la technologie à de la
science n'est arrivé de se dire à un
point tel que au début de l'année je ne
connaissais rien mélangez pu développer
un système en intelligence artificielle
ou encore un jeu vidéo
kuan yew aussi de se dire que on est là
on ne se connaissait pas on arrive à
faire bouger un robot est en fait c'est
pas nous qui faisons le robot mais c'est
le robot qui nous construit parce que ce
n'est pas seulement de développer des
techniques à mettre de l'avant avec
d'autres personnes
mais c'est vraiment de se dire de quelle
façon je peux collaborer avec des gens
que je ne connais pas que je suis
capable de faire des alliances pour
aller plus loin pour voir qu'est ce que
les robots à côté du mien ne font plus
que le mien ne fait pas certaines choses
je suis capable d'aller chercher les
compétences du robot d'à côté quan eu
aussi qu'être dans sa propre école et
pouvoir changer l'aménagement de son
école que ce soit pas juste un bénéfice
pour nos amis nos collègues de classe ou
de l'école mais que la communauté puisse
bénéficier également de ces places là
qu'ont réalisé que de voir les voisins
bénéficier de notre cour d'école quand
on est un jeune aussi dans des
communautés autochtones et qu'on est
peut-être introverti et qu'on ait de la
difficulté de s'exprimer devenir une
inspiration dans sa communauté devenir
une inspiration pour les jeunes autour
de nous parce qu'on a pu développer
certaines compétences en classe que
normalement dans un système normal on
n'y arriverait pas de monter en fait une
performance de se faire remettre des
prix à la fin de l'année de pouvoir voir
aussi qu'avec ses amis
on arrive à créer produits autour d'une
idée est de pouvoir faire comme on dit
en bon français notre pitch que les gens
rentrent dans notre notre univers et
crois en ce que nous sommes capables de
faire ça prend un village pour élever
des enfants des jeunes
ça prend aussi une vision donc
l'éducation du futur c'est tout le monde
ensemble qu'on arrive à la faire nous
aujourd'hui vous qui m'écoutent et vous
êtes universitaire peut-être vous faites
partie d'une certaine entreprise comment
s'impliquer en fait auprès de ces jeunes
le comment faire la différence autour de
ce parcours l'éducation ça se fait pas
seulement à l'école ça se fait à l'école
oui parce qu'on a quand même un certain
système qui vient accompagner tout ça
mais vous pouvez également faire partie
du village des enfants pour changer leur
perspective de les accompagner de voir
de quelle façon on fait ensemble on peut
faire la différence
donc ce que je vous invite ce soir c'est
vraiment de regarder autour de vous ou
vous pouvez vraiment aller et pouvoir
aider ou encore remarqué que ce n'est
pas seulement vous qui allez apporter
une aide certaines à quelque chose qui
pourrait être réalisé mais qu à travers
vos implication vous allez pouvoir vous
également en apprendre énormément les
jeunes vous seront à jamais
reconnaissants ils sont des éponges
ils apprennent rapidement on a des
résultats auxquels on n'aurait jamais
pensé qu'on pouvait atteindre
on les prépare en fait pour la société
oui c'est un modèle qui a vu lieu qui a
vu le jour à montréal
mais aujourd'hui la persévérance
scolaire est quand même pas seulement
ciblées en milieu urbain en milieu
québécois non plus donc le modèle et
développez également en ontario on s'en
va bientôt vers le nouveau-brunswick en
apprenant ce qu'on faisait si la france
maintenant veux qu'on travaille avec eux
et évidemment comme c'est un modèle qui
parle du sis faut toujours garder notre
essence aussi parce qu'on a cette
ouverture le que certaines sociétés
n'ont pas et c'est probablement nos
jeunes d'ici qui
accompagné des jeunes d'ailleurs pour
qu'ils puissent être mieux outillés donc
je vous invite ce soir vraiment à faire
partie de cette éducation du futur là
pour la société du futur
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]